trials fusion may never come to the Vita
but if you're desperate for a bit of
portability or milk plays always an
option so how does it perform let's take
a look if you're paying close attention
to the video you probably notice how
choppy it moves fusion on the
PlayStation 4 moves that is silky smooth
60 frames per second it's much lower
than that when using remote play the
worst part it's an uneven Franklin and
those hitches and sputters can lead to
crashes not fun another difference comes
from how the shoulder buttons are used
the DualShock 4 has analog triggers so
you can gas and brake as much or as
little as you like the Vita doesn't have
this luxury I thought this would spell
doom for remote play but it's not as bad
as it sounds you just have to tap tap
tap your way through the tricky section
instead finally watch out if you have a
twitchy thumb tapping the left side of
the screen instantly restarts you which
can be maddening during a successful run
oh and there's no option to reconfigure
the controls so try to keep your hands
still to avoid screwing yourself over
all told I would never choose to use
remote play if I have other options but
if your television is occupied Crouse
fusion performs well enough on the Vita
maybe someday we'll get an actual Vita
port but until that happy day arrives
we'll just have to settle for a
second-rate experience